the program China's top legislative body
has unanimously approved a national
security law for the territory that may
crush political freedoms it's the most
far-reaching development in Hong Kong's
history ever since it was handed over to
China in 1997 acts of subversion could
now face a maximum sentence of life in
jail
critics say it'll be used to stamp out
all forms of dissent and it comes after
months of mass unrest sparked by fears
of China's tightening grip on Hong Kong
the legislation aims to cement Beijing's
control over the semi-autonomous
territory and reshape the future of one
of the world's major financial centres
Adrian Brown is standing by for us with
reaction out of Hong Kong first let's
cross over to Beijing where Katrina u is
waited for us in Katrina really just
talk us through the process of what we
know about how this law and legislation
has been discussed in Beijing we know
that China's Standing Committee its top
legislative body met at 9:00 a.m. today
on Tuesday to discuss this and shortly
after to vote on this soren shortly
after it was passed unanimously now only
one member of that Stanley committee is
a is from Hong Kong but they did have 12
observers from Hong Kong during the
discussion of this law which has taken
place since Sunday now you know it's a
hefty law it consists of six chapters
with 66 different articles underneath
that and what is most concerning some
legal experts is that state media here
have flagged the fact that Beijing will
have jurisdiction over very few of those
crimes meeting that extradition to the
mainland will be possible also we know
that life imprisonment could be one of
the heavier or the heaviest penalties
for breaking any of these crimes
mentioned in this law we're still still
waiting on more details we should have
that later on today but moving forward
we know there will be a national
security office set up in Hong Kong most
likely to be headed by somebody in
China's and Ministry of Public Security
somebody involved in intelligence and
there are a few more steps before the
small is actually implemented but
ultimately it will be inserted into Hong
Kong's Basic Law its mini Constitution
completely bypassing
Kong's own legislative process and we
have to remember that this has been a
tremendously fast-tracked process it's
been just about 40 days since this
national security law was first
announced during China's National
People's Congress its largest political
gathering earlier this year and usually
these laws takes years at least a year
for this to be passed and that really
does demonstrate Beijing's determination
to stamp out this pro-democracy protests
which many say are basically have been a
threat to Beijing's power in Hong Kong
for its part China's leaders say that
that is not the case this national
security law is about protecting Hong
Kong's stability Hong Kong's prosperity
this is all about a fresh new start for
Hong Kong but regardless we have to also
look finally at the timing of this
tomorrow is July the first the
anniversary of Hong Kong's handover from
Britain back to China and ultimately
Beijing seems to be sending a very
strong message and that is that in Hong
Kong
it is Beijing that is in charge Catrina
you in Beijing thank you well let's get
reaction now from Hong Kong Adrienne
Brown is our correspondent standing by
for us and since we heard the news just
a few hours ago Adrienne we've been
wondering what the reaction would be
from Hong Kong we're now getting more
voices speaking pro-democracy leaders
now speaking about their future
intentions what more do we know yes
that's absolutely right even before
local media announced that this law had
been passed it was already beginning to
have a chilling effect now Joshua Wong a
well-known young democracy activist has
said that he's going to be resigning
from the political party he helped to
set up
he believes he'll be a target of this
new security law and he says he's
leaving the party in order to practice
his own beliefs privately also another
member of the same party Nathan law has
also announced his resignation and a
smaller pro-democracy party called the
Hong Kong National Front has also
announced its disbanding so you can see
the effect already that the law is
starting to have and I think actually
that will please China's leaders because
this
or more than anything else I think is
there as a warning
now China has said in the past this law
was coming it had warned that certain
red lines had been crossed it had said
there would be consequences now we're
seeing those consequences in action
we've also been hearing from Carolyn the
embattled chief executive of Hong Kong
who his contree nough mentioned has been
completely bypassed in this process
along with her legislature but she
dodged questions about the new law at
her Tuesday morning media conference she
said she won't comment until the law has
actually been confirmed as having been
passed and we expect to have that
confirmation later this afternoon as
well as confirmed details of exactly
what this law contains but according to
state media during the past few weeks
this law will allow mainland agents to
operate legally on the ground here in
Hong Kong where a new security body is
also going to be established so this
without dales without doubt sohail is
the most profound impact the most
profound decision on Hong Kong since the
handover from Britain to China almost 23
years ago of course it is a developing
story we'll check in with you later
with that Adrienne Brown there in Hong
Kong thank you well while China's top
legislature has kept the draft of the
law under wraps some details have
emerged over the past few weeks so let's
take a look at those the law
criminalizes acts of secession
subversion and terrorism and collusion
with foreign forces and as we have been
saying it'll also allow members of the
Chinese security services to set up and
operate an agency in Hong Kong Beijing
will get jurisdiction over some national
security cases related to the city
finally it'll give Hong Kong's leader to
power at the power to choose judges that
will preside over cases while Tammy Tran
is a legislator and convener of the
pro-democracy camp in Hong Kong she
joins me now via Skype good to have you
with us on the program it does seem that
China has circumvented the legislature
in Hong Kong
how significant is that in the way that
china now deals with Hong Kong in the
future well by passing this law I would
say this is like a death certificate of
one country two systems' back in the 90s
the Chinese government had promised not
only to Hong Kong people but to the
world that Hong Kong will implement one
country two systems that means we can
keep our own judiciary the legislature
as well as the own administration but
now you can see that by passing this law
within like 40 days without any
consultation in Hong Kong without
disclosing the details of this
legislation
there's definitely bypassing the
administration as well as the
legislation in Hong Kong and the details
that you have mentioned of course it's
not confirmed yet but you can see that
not only the legislature and the
administration is under pressure you can
see also our judicial independence is
also also under very great pressure in a
sense that it may affect the Hong Kong
judiciary in the long run do you think
that you will have any useful part in
Hong Kong's future in the weeks months
and years ahead or are you now obsolete
well it's really very much depends on
whether we can whether the Chinese
government still respect the legislature
because in Hong Kong we can all we
always have freedom of speech we can
always have a freedom of expression but
under this legislation which likely will
be promulgated tomorrow are all our
freedom and rights are still protected
under our basic law or whether this law
will come about or our Hong Kong local
legislature as well as the basic law so
that means our future is very uncertain
although some people said that this
legislature would only affect a small
number of people but you can see that
under the definition of national
security in China it covers a very very
wide range of aspects for example I
economies education as well as religion
yeah so I really don't know what's what
will happen in even tomorrow so it's
very much depends on whether our
administration will exercise
self-restraint mr. Trump very briefly
then I want to ask you about your
reaction to news at Joshua Wong and
Nathan law are stepping down from you
might say the high profile role they've
played in pro in the pro-democracy
movement in Hong Kong what's your
reaction to that and do you expect the
international community to take you may
say the mantle of criticism of the way
Beijing have handled this to protect the
likes of Joshua Wong and Nathan law well
by passing this law within such a short
period of time I do believe that the
Chinese government have this very strong
determination not only to send a warning
but probably will take action that's of
course I'm a bit pessimistic but I I
totally of course respect the decision
of Nathan as well as Joshua but I
understand that they are under great
pressure but at the same time I think
they they would continue to fight for
democracy in their own ways but I do
believe that the impact will will will
be will be more so we can we may we may
see some more impact on not even the
younger generations but also some other
political parties or organization in in
the near future okay we shall see what
happens to Nia chan joining us from Hong
Kong thank you very much for your time
thank you